we are entering day seven of the trial
of a former Dallas police officer who
shot and killed her neighbor in his
apartment last September
this comes as we hear from the victim's
family for the very first time they
hosted a gala yesterday on what would
have been both of John's 28th birthday
Omar Villafranca is at the Frank Crowley
courthouse in Dallas with more on the
story so Omar why could today be so
critical for this case well we could
hear some more expert testimony and
possibly closing arguments meanwhile the
Jean family is trying to find strength
by honoring his life I am just in awe of
what we are seeing today Sunday night in
Dallas was the official US launch of the
both Amjad foundation it was a formal
red tide and red carpet fundraising gala
and birthday celebration for the young
man with a promising future I think it's
a demonstration of transition of pain
that were going through into power the
red tie event comes just two days after
former Dallas police officer
amber Geiger testified she killed John
in self-defense mistakingly thinking he
was a burglar in her apartment last
September Geiger told investigators she
entered the wrong level of their
apartment complex and walked into John's
unlocked door thinking it was her own
[Laughter]
yes sir
early Wiley is a former judge and
district attorney in Kaufman County just
outside of Dallas she says based on the
evidence she believes the jury will have
a difficult time finding Giger guilty of
murder I don't know how you could ever
explain a mistake like that how you
could ever live with that but is she
criminally guilty from my training
experience she may not be
we will still continue to honor him and
to continue his legacy
Geiger faces life in prison if she's
convicted of murder but today we could
also hear if the judge is going to allow
the jury to consider lesser charges like
criminally negligent homicide or
manslaughter Court is back in session at
9:30 Anthony my thanks could be a
controversial verdict no matter what